I always want the scenes to work on a
few different levels when it comes to
dealing with genre I want to you know I
want to transcend the genre but I don't
want it to be an art film meditation on
genre I wanted to deliver the goods Rick
is the one who pretends to be the badass
Cowboy the guy who can do this and the
guy who can do that and Cliff is the guy
just watched Rick spending his day on
the Lancer set playing a cowboy in his
Cowboy outfit all right walking down
Western streets cut to Cliffs showing up
on a western town so now I'm playing out
the same masculine Western fantasy kind
of for real all right where I just
played it for for the artificiality of
it all now he gets to play out for real
but with real consequences you wouldn't
think that Rick would die but
dramatically Cliff could die there's a
lot of different unspoken ways that that
scene works that don't present itself on
the surface and I don't really want you
to think about it on the surface but you
feel it on the inside